sehr geehrte damen und herren zu hause
geschätzte soldaten ich darf sie recht
herzlich zur angelobung der rekruten des
ein rückgangs termines jänner 2022 der
zweiten garde komponiert begrüßen sie
sehen am linken flügel eine
ehrenformation gestellt durch die
gardemusik und die vierte kompanie
192 an zu geloben der rekruten der
zweiten garde company bilden die front
und den rechten flügel
ich darf ihnen kurz den ablauf näher
bringen in kürze erfolgt das ankündigung
signal die volks- und einer meldung des
gesamt kommandierenden an den
militärkommandanten von wien herrn
brigadier magister kurt warner nach dem
abspielen der bundeshymne und dem
abschreiten der front folgt die
flaggenparade
der mit der führung beauftragte
commander garde oberstleutnant thomas
pütters berger mit der begrüßung der
ehrengäste durchführen und nach einem
choral hören wir die worte der
geistlichkeit
mag die ansprache des
militärkommandanten und einem musikstück
hören sie die worte des abgeordneten zum
wiener landtages und vertreter des
bürgermeisters von wien herr magister
marcus schober
eine fanfare leitet zum eigentlichen
höhepunkt dieser veranstaltung dem
treuegelöbnis über den abschluss bildet
das musikstück oder um eine österreich
und das er bieten weitere befehle nach
dem abrücken der ehrenformation endet
die feierliche angelobung
[Musik]
ehrenkompanie schon
ehrenkompanie presse
[Musik]
das ganze recht
eine ehrenkompanie sowie 192 gelogen
allen guten zur feierlichen angelobung
angetreten
[Musik]
das ganze
wäre company
ehrenkompanie
präsentiert
das ganze
heft
[Musik]
das ganze
eher company
ehrenkompanie
daheim gut
das ganze hat
gut
zusätzlich kameraden der zweiten jahre
jüngeren soldaten
ich darf sie heute hier begrüßen in
maria theresien kaserne nach durch
fordernden wochen am truppenübungsplatz
und knauf und ich hoffe dass das heute
die letzte angelobung unter ausschluss
der öffentlichkeit ist dass wir in
zukunft wieder angehörige zu dieser
veranstaltung einladen dürfen war es
natürlich eine besondere aufwertung für
die anzüge letzten rekruten darstellen
wird es sind trotzdem einige ehrengäste
heute zur an gelungen erschienen und ich
darf an der spitze besondere gäste heute
begrüßen nämlich eine relegation des
serbischen sicherheits und
verteidigungsausschusses des parlaments
vertreten darf ich den botschafter seine
exzellenz herr botsch begrüßen herzlich
willkommen
in vertretung ist bürgermeister von wien
darf ich den herrn abgeordneten zum
landtag michael schober begrüßen
ein willkommensgruß gilt den
militärkommandanten von wien er bringt
ihr mann ist wegen heftiger hier
ein aufrichtiges und herzliches grüß
gott biete ich den vertretern der
militär geistlichkeit herrn merz dekan
dr altrip von der evangelischen
militärseelsorge mit der oberpfarrer
magister wilfried scheidt
priester vater alexander lappin von der
orthodoxie militärseelsorge und den
islamischen mit der seelsorger kennen
krawiec grüß gott der
in vertretung der frau
bezirksvorsteherin unsere heimat
bezirkes liezen darf ich den
stellvertretenden
bezirksvorsteher kommerzialrat christian
gerzabek herzlich willkommen heißt es
ganz
herzlich kann man an der zweiten
kompanie
wie schon erwähnt liegen durch fordern
die wochen hinter ihnen sie sind quasi
durchs fegefeuer gegangen und werden
sich hoffentlich dadurch die hölle
ersparen sie werden in ihren
verschiedenen funktionen dienst versehen
egal in welcher funktion sie dann
dienste fortsetzen
ist die
leistungsbereitschaft und die bereits
anerzogene und angelernte disziplin
wesentlicher bestandteil für ihren
erfolgreichen beitrag im
österreichischen bundesheer
wie so viele kameraden vor ihnen schon
bei der jahre und im österreichischen
bundesheer gedient haben jetzt sind sie
an der reihe für meine gardesoldaten
wird es eine überaus interessante aber
auch fordernde ausbildung geben
und ich bedanke mich bei allen kameraden
der zweiten jahren komponiert für die
bisher gezeigte leistungsbereitschaft
und wünsche ihnen für die weitere
verwendung für die weitere ausbildung
viel zu laden
[Musik]
sehr geehrter herr botschafter exzellenz
werte delegation bravo de toyota
lieber herr militärkommandant hergarten
kommandant werte kamera der zweiten
garde kompanie sie werden heute angelobt
in nicht einfachen zeiten unserer
gemeinsamen europäischen heimat
herausforderungen entwicklungen die auf
uns alle wirken und wirken werden es
braucht den schutz des allmächtigen
gottes von oben und in dieser stunde
darf ich ihnen wo sich das gelohnt es
sprechen werden auf unsere republik und
diese republik auch entsprechend zu
verteidigen den schutz von oben so
bieten wir herrn du kennst unsere
schwäche du weißt vielleicht wird den
mut verlieren du weißt wie ängstlich wir
unsere schritte setzen
aber du hast uns gerufen
darauf verlassen die uns wir wissen
nicht ob etwas herauskommt bei allem was
wir in deinem namen tun
aber das werkzeug braucht sich nicht zu
ängstigen um den sinn des werkes du hast
uns in die hand genommen
brauche uns
ich wünsche ihnen allen gottes schutz
gottes segen für ihren dienst voller
herausforderungen liebe kameraden der
erst in den nächsten wochen und monaten
erwarten wird gott schütze sie
idee willi meibeck
deprag oslo wir
alles gute
sehr geehrte gäste aus serbien werte
kameraden sehr geehrte kommandanten
liebe anzüge lobende ich darf ihnen denn
für heute ausgelosten
bibelvers vorlesen aus den befehl seyer
25 vers 8
und in ihnen mitgeben in die irc zu
kommende zeit der herr wird aufheben die
schmach seines volks in allen landen
wir sind hier beim propheten jesaja an
einer stelle wo in die zukunft schaut
dass das kommen wird und die ersten
werden dankes lieder singen und gott
wird etwas besonderes tun er wird die
hülle entfernen die decke weg nehmen die
menschen aus allen völkern werden kommen
und überall werden sie gottes
herrlichkeit sehen können und
dann der beamer verwirrt aufheben dich
mag er wird die tränen von allen
anwesenden
abwischen viel wird geschehen aber es
steht immer noch aus im gottvertrauen
dürfen wir darauf hoffen dass es früher
oder später geschehen wird er wird
befreien er wird die decke wegziehen und
alle werden begreifen und sehen wäre ist
nämlich gott und dieses gottvertrauen
möchte ich ihnen auch zu sprechen und
ihnen mitgeben
dass gott gott ist
wenn ich an die grenze komme und besuch
mache
bei den posten dann werde ich auch gerne
gefragt ob ich dienstaufsicht mache und
ich sage dann ich bin wegen ihrer
seligkeit heraus
und das meint so viel dass wir gemeinsam
auf gott vertrauen auf ihn hoffen können
das gut ist und muss nah ist
wir haben wir uns im bundesheer unter
militärkommando wien auch die letzten
zwei jahre ganz anders vorgestellt aber
es war klar dass wir als strategische
reserve republik österreich
überall dort eingesetzt wurden und
unterstützt haben wo das andere nicht
noch nicht oder nicht mehr konnten und
so waren wir an vielen orten im einsatz
um unterstützung und hilfe leistung zu
bringen bei zivilen einrichtungen
der post bei logistikunternehmen
bei völkerrechts objekten wo er für die
sicherheit von botschaften und
internationalen organisationen und
anderen gefährdeten objekten suchen
oder an der grenze
im burgenland und in niederösterreich wo
wir bereits tätig war und überall bei
diesen einsätzen
war die garde
nicht nur dabei sondern an vorderster
stelle eingesetzt vom ersten moment an
bis heute
und sie die regionen der zweiten garde
company sind auch zwar erst seit wenigen
wochen aber auch teilen dieses vorzeige
verband der karte
und sie werden nur in wenigen
augenblicken
in treuegelöbnis
sagen dass sie persönlich ihren beitrag
leisten werden
für den schutz und die sicherheit
österreichs
und dieser beitrag kann
bald von innen eingefordert werden und
zwar in welcher funktion auch immer sie
jetzt tätig sein werden ob sie bei der
garten verbleiben und damit bei der
repräsentation tätig sein werden
darunter auch einige touristische
einsatz soldat sein werden oder ob sie
den betrieb verwendet werden
als soldat oder
in der küche oder wo auch immer als
kraftfahrer überall dort werden sie
gefordert werden wo überall dort können
sie auch einen beitrag leisten zur
auftragserfüllung des bundesheeres und
um diesen beitrag zur auftragserfüllung
des bundesheeres ersuche ich ersuche sie
sich mit allen ihren fähigkeiten
fertigkeiten und kenntnissen die sie
haben für den dienst im bundesheer
einzusetzen dann werden sie persönlich
auch sehr viel positives aus diesen
dienst für österreich mitnehmen in
diesem sinne wünsche ich ihnen als
militärkommandant von wänden für die
nächsten wochen und monaten dass er
alles erdenklich gute viel glück und
erfolg
[Musik]
[Applaus]
exzellenz sagte der militärkommandant
hohe geistlichkeit werte ehrengäste aber
vor allem die werte rekruten in
vertretung von bürgermeister michael
ludwig da hatte ich mich bei ihnen
bedanken dass ich den dienst bei
österreichischen bundesheer entschieden
haben haben von ihrem kommandanten schon
gehört wäre ausbildung ausgesehen hat
und erlauben sie mir auch einige worte
zur aktuellen europäischen lage zu sein
die großmächte der weltpolitik haben
strategische interessen die haben sie
weltweit unterstehen auch
unterschiedliche systeme in diesen
strategischen überlegungen das
beinhaltet
konfliktpotenziale die sich aktuell in
der ukraine verhärten
unseren anderen zwei weltkriegen
schmerzvoller leben müssen was krieg
bedeutet und wie viel elend krieg bringt
wie es republik haben eine historische
verantwortung übernommen wenn es darum
geht sich für frieden einzusetzen
österreich positioniert sich seit 1955
als friedensvermittler unterwelt und da
bereits auf bewiesen dass wir ein ort
des dialogs sind und ein ort der
unterschiedliche meinungen positionen
und systeme zusammenbringen kann
durch dieses engagement ist es uns
gelungen ohne sitz zu werden wo es cds
zu werden sind wichtige einrichtungen zu
sein
als neutrales land im herzen europas
wird österreich für sein
friedensengagement sehr hoch geschätzt
auch das bundesheer trägt mit seinen
zahlreichen friedenseinsätzen dazu bei
international wirken wir somit als
friedensstifter in vielen ländern ich
möchte ich immer wieder betonen dass
1000 soldaten und soldatinnen
permanent im friedenseinsatz tätig sind
und ich würde mir wünschen dass darüber
er berichtet wird aber das bundesheer
garantiert auch unsere nationale
souveränität und unsere neutralität auch
wenn die situation angespannt ist
unser heer ist die strategische reserve
unserer republik wie man gesehen hat und
ein militärkommandant und der gerade
kommandant schon gesagt keiner hätte
sich vorgestellt in den letzten zwei
jahren war es auf das bundesheer zukommt
was zu leisten ist und was auch
geleistet wurden ich möchte nicht mehr
ohne party erinnern sondern mich auch
bedanken für die brandbekämpfung im
reichsgebiet und viele viele weitere
einsätze ohne im einsatz wehrte rekruten
wäre das nicht möglich und sie wirken
zusammen mit berufssoldaten soldatinnen
medizin daten und soldatinnen uns gehört
das in den unterschiedlichsten
funktionen eingesetzt werden und dafür
möchte ich mich bedanken
es stehen gewiss schwierige zeiten vor
uns und ich glaube fest daran dass
österreich mitwirken kann mit
diplomatischen geschick das nur noch
dinge verändern kann meine gedanken sind
heute nicht nur meine ist und ich glaube
alle unsere gedanken sind bei der
zivilbevölkerung der ukraine aber
auch bei den soldaten beider seiten
möge die politik rasch wege finden dass
ein unnötiges blutvergießen auf
europäischen boden bald wieder vermieden
werden kann
ich wünsche ihnen bei ihren aufgaben
alles gute sie haben schon gehört ich
wünsche ihnen soldatenglück ich wünsche
ihnen das beste und schließlich mit den
worten es lebe das österreichische
bundesheer es lebe die republik
österreich
es lebe der frieden in europa
[Musik]
das könnte
in siegen druck der garde vertreten
[Musik]
eingeteilte rekruten vortreten
rekruten zum gemerkt
wie guten sprecht mir nach ich glaube
mein vaterland
die republik österreich
und sein volk zu schützen und
mit der waffe zu verteidigen
ich glaube
die gesetzen und gesetzmäßigen behörden
treue und die usa zugleich sehen
alle befehle meiner vorgesetzten
möglich und die laut zu befolgen und
mit alle meine kräfte
der republik österreich und
dem österreichischen volk
[Musik]
vom
eingeteilte guten eintritte
in sie gedruckter garde antreten
[Musik]
das ganze parade
das ganze
ehrenkompanie
ehrenkompanie presse die
das ganze
[Musik]
erträge die haupt nunmehr behindert die
meldet die beendigung des festaktes und
bittet um weitere befehle
das ganze
hab ich
komponiere komponiert übernehmen
abrücken
[Musik]